I'm Nick Cannon and I'm going undercover
on the Internet
this is actually me Instagram did you
say that you were against tattoos in
your earlier years something about your
body as the temple hood so you didn't
want to ink up my wrong I definitely say
that look at the hypocrite that I am at
that time I did because growing up I was
super religious and grew up in a
household where your body is considered
your temple which I still believe that
there's now a monk
tickle got some graffiti on it like some
artwork on the outside but I still
believe my body is a temple what does
the headway represent to you I respected
the head where people call it many
different things a Death Star curving
head rat ultimately it's a sign of
sovereignty self-governance throughout
the ages throughout the years whether
it's the seek understanding or there's
more science an individual who wears a
turban is always considered as a
safe-haven or someone that can offer
guidance and assistance when there
weren't law enforcement or police
organizations in certain communities and
you still see that today I mean there's
a lot of misconceptions and stereotypes
that have been perpetuated since Ben but
the people who wear them and stick true
to the form it's all about discipline
and sovereignty I definitely consider
myself to be sovereign and self governed
in anti-authoritarian hahaha but I don't
think I give good advice click IMDB
formed the rap duo the bomb squad with
his best friend they opened for the
likes of Will Smith LFO 98 degrees in
Montell Jordan early on when I was a
teenager I definitely formed a rap group
called the bomb squad with my best
friend and the only person that as a
group we opened up for that's on this
list is Montell Jordan which was you
know this is how we do it guys so I was
pretty big for me coming from San Diego
and being alone
rapper but then the biggest act that we
opened up for happen to be Outkast which
actually I felt like helped propel me to
be able to get the opportunity to go to
Hollywood and perform quite a bit as not
only a rapper but also as a stand-up
comedian which then allowed me to open
up for all of these other people on the
list Will Smith which I didn't really
open I performed for him and then
obviously he became my mentor so we have
done shows and stuff like that together
I never like really opened up for Will
but definitely LFO and 98° because by
the time those acts came out I was on
Nickelodeon hosting performing making
music so all of these things are true
they just happen in different timeframes
in my life I sleep I flick someone
what's that like to ticket a scam it was
like baskets just you try to put words
together really fast it's like it wasn't
good mix for Instagram
what are your do's and don'ts when it
comes to foods that trigger your lupus I
also have lupus and I never knew which
foods would trigger that's interesting I
actually had this actual conversation
with my doctor this morning they
diagnosed me with lupus nephritis
it was my immune system attacking my
organs scientifically has yet to be
proven but I actually do believe the
things that you put in your body and
create a very electric diet that you can
prevent different players but ultimately
I truly believe water is like the secret
elixir to all problems on the planet
this is from Twitter how doesn't it can
and continue to find his way into
literally every single celebrity a scam
ever played I don't know if it's every
single one but I've kind of been around
for a long time so you know obviously
back in the day we would do like rocking
jock stuff on MTV or even we do stuff on
Nickelodeon and now I've always been a
friend and fan of the NBA I'm not even
that good at basketball I don't suck
though I'm very athletic I'm not a
competitive type of guy I think a lot of
people when I playing those games they
get upset when because I don't take it
seriously like I'll be on the sidelines
eating nachos trying to crack jokes cuz
we're competing oh yeah
cannon received his first break doing
stand-up comedy on his father's local
cable access program pretty true I don't
know if that's where I received my first
break I would say public access or cable
access as they call it sometimes is the
place where I kind of learn the game or
it's kind of like a training ground for
me for what my real career would end up
becoming if anyone has ever worked in
cable access you know you got three cool
at all and I learned that stuff that
like 11 years old because my dad did
have his own public access program as a
reward he would give me like the
opportunity to have free time for myself
with the cameras and do whatever I
wanted so I would just like do comedy
skits and this is obviously way before
there was a youtube or any of that stuff
so these things but actually air on
television and I would be rapping and
I'd go to school I saw you on TV dressed
up as an old lady rappers just me kind
of exploring doing silly stuff I was
like a preteen that world then turned
into stand-up comedy and you know as my
dad would go around preaching and
speaking in different churches and
events I would kind of open up for the
preacher man and here we are today click
this looks like Twitter Nick Cannon
what was your workout routine for
drumline preseason Luke rule in my dude
Joe I was interesting because that was
obviously my first starring role so I
had the opportunity to just dive all the
way in as a leading man but then someone
who
wanted to show that I took this entire
process seriously I dedicated myself as
a true snare drummer so we went out
there a few months before we started
filming and get like six to eight hours
every day of this drumming for weeks I
would sleep with the drumsticks in my
hand just to try to get used to it cuz I
you know I've always messed around with
instruments you know just coming up in
the church and society musical ability
it could mess around on a standard set
but I had never done course style
marching and really the trick was to
learn the cadences that I needed to
learn for the movie and only those
Cadence's and master those so I wouldn't
have to necessarily rely on my double or
any of that stuff and like it worked the
majority of the drumming in the film is
me more Twitter
how come Nick Cannon doesn't wear socks
this is style thing I mean when you
wearing loafers I don't think I'm the
first and they looked a little confusing
if I don't have on socks or my pants are
tapered a little too high or my suits
might be more fitted than the average
person what is this fashion choices
trying to do something that's a little
bit forward than what the average person
would do but I don't think my feet were
stinky I mean I put like baby powder in
the shoes next in 2015 Canon was named
chief creative officer for the
now-defunct British act according to the
company this role involve creating Radio
Shack exclusive products to curating the
in-store experience Radio Shack chose
him in hopes of catering to a younger
crowd the reason that actually happened
cuz I was always a huge fan and still AM
a Radio Shack that's the first place I
ever got my first DJ mixer my first
microphone my first keyboard on a
neighborhood where I didn't necessarily
have a male figure to show me how to
work all of that stuff I could always go
to Radio Shack and they would help me
hook up my Quitman this is like a young
age like nine ten years old I remember
telling that story to the board at Radio
Shack at the time and you know I've been
doing a lot of business with them with
my headphones and other consumer
electronic products and they're like you
probably could help us out and they're
in a state where you know they were
making some company shifts and different
choices as a brand and they definitely
needed to tap it to the younger market
so we got together we did some really
cool thing but apparently they're now
default
oh I don't know how how successful my
chief creative officer duties were but
we had a lot of fun Instagram more
pictures of meat punching brakes Nick
who is that a picture of on your arm
with a head of what is in her ooh that
is actually and it's not hurt that's a
comic book character by the name of dr.
shellacking it was like a mastermind
when it comes to life music and
programming I believe that's a heart a
live flesh blood pumping heart in dr.
Sherlock insane Wikipedia's cannon is
now the chairman of teammate for
Nickelodeon and the development of
creative consultant of the network since
2009 yeah as time went by so fast -
other than for like ten years being the
chairman of team making you know we
developed some really cool things from
the Halo Awards to a teammate top 10 -
Nick music you know still doing some
really fun stuff with Nickelodeon as
well in the music space and yeah I mean
I've been a part of Nickelodeon my
entire career so I remember being 17
years old and being the youngest
television staff writer in television
history and saying like I want to go
further like one day I'm gonna be
running this place and then you know ten
years from then I was like the youngest
television chairman in television
history so to be able to now to look
back in almost you know definitely over
20 years of being in business with
Nickelodeon and being in entertainment
the things that I've accomplished
sometimes I forget about it yeah every
kid born like before 1995 thinks I
started Nickelodeon
how did Nick Cannon influence Society
this is a real question then I mean um
I'm honored but ultimately obviously
from wildin out - feel like we kind of
put our mark on like freestyle comedy in
an improv comedy and in the world of
hip-hop and then also you know I always
say from my fashion choices what I stand
for for my community I definitely try to
enforce and embrace
being different and being yourself in
not trying to fit in by any means
thinking outside the box
not allowing opinions of others to sway
so I'm honored I never thought that I
influence society so I'm rolling with it
yeah Nick Cannon wrote a children's book
what do they call wild a naptime
that's a good title she's funny we
suggest her as a writer I write a bunch
of children's books actually one of the
[Music]
festive creativity on that but then
probably the one that I'm most excited
about and then kind of ventured off into
many different books and titles as a
book of poetry that I wrote called neon
aliens ate my homework and it's in a
very shel silverstein type of format
where it's over a hundred poems just
dealing like the zany silly quirky world
but also the inspirational space and
it's just a bunch of great poems
currently Canon hosts his own show
canons class it's funny I've never even
considered canons class so it's just
actually something I do at Howard
University like I said I question
everything even things that I feel like
I already know I still questioning and
to sit with experts on different fields
and just ask them questions and
sometimes questions that we all want to
know or we don't ever get the
opportunity to ask and then we
documented in a podcast form of
attending we also building curriculum to
go along with it to create other
discussions online I feel like it's just
an informative platform and I think that
is refreshing and informative to the
audience that it receives college isn't
for everyone but I believe education is
for everyone
we all seek after different things but I
think ultimately whatever that
information is however we consume it you
know to build one's mind is definitely
wanted to read
some minute thank you all for watching
that was actually me